democratic nominee joe biden leads the
president in two
more closely fought states according to
our cbs news battleground
tracker poll conducted last week it
shows that former vice president
is nine points ahead in minnesota a
state that is a priority for the trump
campaign biden also leads by three
points in arizona and that state has
only gone to democrats
one time since 1952. think about that
overall our poll finds that arizona
voters are mostly uneasy about the state
of our country right now
only 10 percent say they feel secure
about things at the moment ed o'keefe is
covering campaign 2020 for us with
50 days to go before election day ed
good morning to you
arizona is a very interesting case about
50 percent of the voters overall there
according to our poll say they
blame president trump for the
coronavirus situation there
only a third give him credit for his
response so
is his com are his comments to to bob
woodward having an impact there
well i think overall what the woodward
book continues to do is just sort of
reinforce
what many people had already believed
and that is that there were problems and
there remain problems
with how the federal government with how
the trump administration is responding
to the virus woodward has provided a
very detailed public history
of what's been going on over the last
several months but there isn't really
anyone's mind left to be changed in
arizona we find about two-thirds of
people concerned
about the coronavirus situation the more
concerned you are about it the more
likely you are to be voting for joe
biden therefore
this is a reminder that whether it's in
the grand canyon state or several others
across the country
if you're concerned about the
coronavirus if you're concerned you're
going to get it if you're concerned
about how the response has gone you're
more inclined to be voting for
biden that dynamic remains in this case
and the president has done little to
move the needle on that question so it's
going to remain a real underlying
problem for him
with 50 days to go and the comment from
the president that continues to echo of
course is that he likes to downplay
the virus speaking of downplaying the
virus he was in nevada over the weekend
appearing to downplay it again by
holding a rally
indoors against the rules in that state
the governor a democrat said it was
reckless and selfish
his own cdc says that what he did is in
the highest risk category
why is the president driving right into
the problem zone here
because he has no problem flouting the
rules of his own federal agencies and he
loves taking on popular democratic
governors he's done it in michigan
he's doing it now in nevada hill he
continues to raise questions about
mayors and governors
who are democrats across the country and
the way that they're leading cities and
states it's all consistent with that
and frankly because his supporters uh
just
don't seem to care and he's okay with
that and so
you know we've seen it whether it was
last week in michigan people show up
they may be holding the mask in their
hand to get in but they don't
necessarily wear it
that's a choice they're making and we'll
see in the next few weeks whether
there's any real
medical or you know health and safety
concern that comes from that yeah we
certainly hope there are not any health
concerns uh his opponent joe
biden took a break from campaigning
friday on the 19th anniversary of
september 11th
and then over the weekend had no public
events which i think surprised some
people
what's he doing and what's his plan for
the week ahead
well he'll be giving a series of remarks
today in delaware about the wildfires
out west and how they contribute to
climate change which is actually one of
the domestic
issues that he remains concerned about
and has presented
some pretty hefty proposals on there's
been some evidence that he's perhaps
shifted
slightly more to the left because of
this campaign season but he likes to
remind people that this is an issue he's
been working on
since he was a senator over several
decades on tuesday he heads to florida a
state he really does need to begin
paying attention to especially
its latino population he'll be making
two stops in central florida
in tampa and in the orlando area there
are warning signs down there
specifically when it comes to latinos
there's no question he's likely to win
the latino vote in that state but he
needs that margin to be as high as
possible
to win the state overall and then later
in the week he heads to minnesota which
our poll shows he's doing well in
because friday is the start of early
voting the president will be in
minnesota as well on friday so they'll
cross paths yet again
in a major battleground state yeah and
by maybe getting some help down in
florida where michael bloomberg has
announced a 100 million dollar
contribution to
ads in that state will make a difference
thank you very much